[Música]
qual é
então não seríamos mais
com vida
agora em obter isso parece que
rotina
eu sou dança e eu gosto
[Música]
e não foi assim
eu
em você
se você ver seus amigos
sorriso
[Música]
cidade da sua mão
Eu não sei como vou saber do coração
eu pareço esse outro que assina e seu amigo
e não demorou muito e para você
eu não era assim
[Música]
o salva-vidas o medo de sentir
perguntou você se volta para o seu sol
pergunte como está seu zumbi
Eu quero que você salve
por você
[Música]
[Aplausos]
não era mais assim
[Música]
sair tenho medo de sentir
ele perguntou o tempo e o sol
tempo juntos
[Música]
você deve manter visto o que eu sinto por você
eu
[Música]